zach and i had been together for
um we had been married for about eight
years and i told him that i had feelings
for um a close friend of mine and that
sparked hundreds of conversations over
um
almost two years yeah
did a terrible job
and i think most people do and you're
trying to undo a lifetime of monogamy so
it was actually you know a really
beautiful time because
we had been together every day for years
and really didn't know each other
wholly and completely so getting to to
know each other all over again and was
really um it was really beautiful
especially in the beginning we didn't
know each other completely this is sad i
mean this this is actually cuckold and
she's leading the whole thing she's like
yeah you're
i'm not really that into you and so i
wanted a boyfriend and then you clearly
spent two years telling me not to and
then i told you i'm gonna do it anyway
and then you were
weak in your conviction and your view of
marriage that you decided to let me burn
down our marriage